can stress increase morning glucose. My hot flashes are worse at night, so I wake up a lot at night either burning up or freezing, not exactly relaxing.
Well, you really want to understand the physiology of that? The answer is if you have healthy adrenals and you have stress and you're waking up at night,
yes, you'll have a higher glucose. The reason the physiology is that cortisol released by your adrenal glands break down glycogen stores, which is the way your body may stores glucose.
So glycogen is a long chain of a bunch of attached glucose molecules stored in your liver.
For night or at night or for needing use, you heard about people going to run a marathon and they do, you know, carbon loading, so they don't need to pass the dinner. Well,
it's been things that have debunked that because you could only store so much glycogen, but you will store glycogen in your liver.
So if you release that is through cortisol release. So if you're under stress, you're going to release more cortisol. It's going to increase your glucose levels because it's breaking down the glycogen stores in your liver, increasing circulating glucose because under stress, you burn more glucose, so you need it. So think about that.
So if you wake up in the middle of the night, what kicks in your adrenal still, so your adrenal's kick in, you release cortisol and you will get a higher. So if you sleep really good, you sleep all night long, you're going to have, you know, all things the same, you're going to have a lower more glucose than if you walk up four times to even go to the bathroom.
In any words, stress, you fell right back asleep, you got up to go to the bathroom, your blood glucose is going to be higher in the morning because you released cortisol just to get up to go to the bathroom.
That's the physiology you know.